[Music]
he was regarded
as a prodigy our first mvp of the summer
2015
is origins 80 carrie kneels dazzled
as a rookie during their first split in
the lcs origin has never dropped below
third
and much of that success has been due to
their 17 year old lady carrie niels
and spearheaded one of the greatest
dynasties in the history of european
league
and for the first time in history the
fourth consecutive
eu lcs title g2 esports are the best
team in europe
he left home to chase glory overseas
come to america was a new challenge for
me as a person as a player
my career is all i have in my life it
sounds a little sad but
it's really my career is everything to
me became one of north america's most
highly touted imports that's venomoth
coming over from g2
two-time european champions certainly
incredible players in their own right
and then zven and mithy the quote best
bot lane in the west
and then just as his dream seemed to be
within reach
it all came crashing down that is the
end of this series and the end of tsm's
perfect record
of attending the playoff finals clutch
gaming
will be the first organization to deny
them their pass to the semis
few superstars have known as many
astronomical highs
the ace courtesy of sven in the european
lcs's g2
esports have tied up the series and
incomprehensible lows
no quick silver sash he is down
he is shut down what is he doing to
baron
as sven neil's jumped on by a lulex does
he have the damage condemned against the
wall
yes he does niels is unstoppable there's
one he's gonna try it
and he may want to get it there we go
double guess the reset jumps on
oh my gosh oh deary me
but the nexus it's going low there's a
double kill for sven they've managed to
finish it daisy
is going to be the only one left and
defend but there's a big nar
oh
oh are you kidding with a big ultimate
for one two
kill two kills and maybe the fifth as
well making up the clean eight the
triple kill coming in for span
boss comes out followed by a flash
mickey and spin like flash forward
got it filled with a double throw with a
triple kill there with a quadra kill
tsm in game number one
will get their kites up the pistol
that's that's it this
is his story
jasper's ven svenningsen was born in
skiva denmark
on june 24 1997 even though he didn't
start playing
league of legends until the age of 13 he
immediately blossomed into something of
a tryhard
very very first time i was playing with
my cousin and my sister's
boyfriend told me hey dude why is to
play
this old game i was playing wow i think
or something and he told me there's this
new game called league of legends
and it was like right before beta was uh
like right after beta was out and he was
like this game is [ __ ] cool go play
it and i was like
okay i'll go sign up on the page you
know i was like uh this game is fine uh
i'll try it out with it didn't take long
for him to realize that he had what it
took
to go pro by 16 he'd solidified himself
as one of europe's most promising
young ad carries i knew for sure that i
was not going to
finish school i was going to go pro
whether it was uh
like i was sure it was going to be
decision no matter what like i was one
month
even before i had offers and i knew i
was going to go pro because i just knew
it you know
i was so good under a variety of handles
flow zvanilan and ultimately meals
he spent the next two years trying to
prove himself on a variety of amateur
and challenger teams
his first notable roster was
intellectual playground
a danish side with whom niels and
santorin achieved
top four finishes in the we play
international and dreamhack winter 2013.
the nexus is completely is exposed an
ipg may just have done this in 51
minute 52 minutes the nexus will fall
and game one of this best of three
series go to intellectual playground
the roster disbanded after failing to
make it out of groups of copenhagen
games 2014 however
and niels took a hiatus from competitive
play ever since that i just chilled a
bit and
placed lucky all day and waited for my
my moment like my opportunity and then
it came
in 2014 at the end of the year niels was
given the opportunity to join origen
a newly formed challenger roster led by
the legendary mid laner expec
i even asked reckless i remember so i
asked him
which idea would you think would be the
best and he told me
if you go with this guy nils i'm pretty
sure you guys will qualify because i
from what i see him playing in solo
queue i think he's completely
one of the best ideas and all he needs
is to improve in a team environment
and it was on origin that niels would
meet a support with whom he would form
not only an enduring friendship
but a world famous lane duo miffy
how i know the story is that pekka just
asked me to where are we going to play
with it in boldly you can choose
it's joko and i think he was between me
and taps at that time
and in the end we just played like some
duo queues and stuff to
as a tryout or whatever and then that's
how it came to be
from the very get-go origin were a force
to be reckoned with
they qualified for the 2015 eucs spring
season
lost only one match during that season
and swept copenhagen wolves academy in
the spring playoff finals to earn
themselves a spot in the eu lcs
this will be going down here stress and
origen
welcome to the lcs because you've just
dominated this series
you've taken the first place in the
spring split
of the challenger series congratulations
as soon as neil set foot into the lcs he
exploded
neil's jumped on by lulex does he have
the damage condemned against the wall
yes he does
niels is unstoppable and he gets some
help from mithy
so we'll find out gosu pepper is down we
do see there's mithy with the head but
pulverized combo betsy's fur rushing
away
with expected out can neil's cleaned up
and the simple answer is yes
he's got himself a double kill as they
turn their attention onto cabo shot
the odd slots of shadows is there just
to keep cabo shot alive
the exhaust will hold him in place as
niels will get himself a triple
look at the bottom window that hips down
that's it
niels gets the kill the flash forward
from the body slam of amazing
gonna get more solace was burning down
faster freddy's looking for the kill
but he's gonna get dropped as niels gets
more not only was neil's awarded rookie
of the split but he broke the lcs record
for highest kda in a single match
and propelled origen to a second place
finish in the 2015 summer split
during their first split in the lcs
origin has never dropped below third
and much of that success has been due to
their 17 year old lady carrie kneels
and their playoff performance was
equally impressive
the nexus turrets are being focused by
the super minions
amazing is trying to push them down as
well and hyonin will
not be able to get more kills h2k
get aced origin they were going to
stockholm
now they're going to stockholm in the
finals come the grand finals they
managed to take two games off a nearly
unbeatable fanatic
origen in the fourth game of the 15 000
goal down and giving away two parents
they're going to force game five
they're going to play silver scrapes the
captain he found the engager going in
fnatic they're going to finish it
they're going to kill the nexus and
they're going to worlds
they will represent europe as the number
one seed
niels had only been in the lcs for one
split and had already qualified for
worlds
despite being overshadowed by an
extremely dominant fanatic
origen put up a strong group stage
performance but it's gonna be enough
no way and origen beat lgd
and they're gonna take down team solomid
knock up coming in from amazing there's
one more let's dive in there
there we go gg
all right yeah how about that origin
these guys are legit man
all right
[Applause]
advanced to the knockout stage and
became the first western team to win a
best of five at worlds
uh-oh carson taking the wrong tunnel
gets up for the wrong exit
there's the last grid to take him out
niels is huge he gets pixie and black
shield and gets sped up he's a one-man
army and there's not nobody can trade
against him
there it times out but look at that you
can't go from the front and anivia wall
blocks off half the passage
state goes in sword art low on health
and here comes the fight karsa killed
off already
sword art should be next black shield
was down they buy a bit of time
another couple of kills come through as
steak has nowhere to go
a few more shots will do it the kills
come in
and this could be the semi finals for
origen there's only one man left alive
this will surely be the base and europe
has a semi
finalist in the world championship as
origen with 3-1
in one year niels had gone from a
challenger series player to lcs rookie
of the split
to a semi-final contender at worlds he
was doing
the impossible there was only one
problem defeating their next opponent
would prove impossible
after all few professional league of
legends teams have gone up against
faker's sk
telecom and lived to tell the tale and
despite all the rallies chants and
thunderous applause
by game three it had become clear this
was always going to be a blowout
there's turret number two there's no
stopping him now
it's time for skt to make it to the
finals
undefeated but niels had become one of
the first westerners to perform well
internationally since the rise of korea
and that was all that mattered he was
being hailed as the rookie of the decade
and it seemed all but certain that niels
was a superstar in the making
after worlds origin hit the ground
running their first tournament was iem
san jose where thanks in part to some
truly inspired niels and miffy plays
origen won the event without dropping a
single game
yeah louie playing with fire
and now that no afro and sticks are very
low here
now if this was double lifted a rocket
jumping in for this one he's gonna try
it
and he may want to get it there
and it was in the wake of this
tournament that the dane adopted the
moniker by which he's known today sven
despite a hiccup at the ensuing iem
world championships
origen entered the 2016 spring split as
strong contenders
but the eu lcs had gotten more
competitive
highlighted by a new threat that had
paved their way from the challenger
series to the top of the eu lcs
the part european part korean powerhouse
known as g2 esports the nexus is
dropping
and with it being killed g2 esports are
the best team in europe
to everyone's surprise origen finished
the split in a stunning
fourth come playoffs however their
characteristic resilience resurfaced
the first one is falling the second is
done shortly
and origen will be performing a clean
sweep
they keep their hopes of another final
alive and now jankos also called out ryu
he's trying to go for the assassinate
but sven he's too slippery he's too good
that's a second kill and now going on to
the nexus itself
the nexus star is going down and against
all odds
origin take down x2k and are your first
finalists
in the spring splits the problem was
that whereas origin were considered to
be the best team made up of europeans
they were no match for the best team in
europe
that's the last nexus turret that's
gonna be it we have a new king in europe
after all
2015 they proved they were lcs material
2016 they're top of the charts
as far as ven and mithy were concerned
that was the last straw
they were widely considered the best
carry support duo in the west
and still hadn't managed to earn a
regional championship never mind an
international one
so they figured if you can't beat them
join them
the move that for me has thus far been
the western blockbuster trade of the
offseason
is sven and mithy sven formerly known as
niels the bot lane
of og origin moving over
to the team they lost to in the final of
the ulcs
spring split g2 formerly called gamers
two
needless to say the transfer invoked
lots of criticism
i don't like talking so much about the
origin stuff because of like
the community backlash that happened and
stuff so it's a bit of a sensitive topic
but
overall the main like goal of the entire
switch was to stay with mithy
that was the most important things i
could go different regions or
a lot of different teams even in eu and
all of them except for one was
alone so there was only one place i
could go with him
and i was here on top of being a good
like
organization and good team it was
the best decision for sure but it worked
within a few months
g2 had plundered their way through the
summer season and were gearing up to
trounce
splice in the final series of the split
after using the abyssal voyage all the
dragon's still the target synthetic he's
gonna get dropped spin
gets the kill credit copies the target
as the chrono break buys more time
sven flashes forward the shutdown kill
spies
are routed they are killed they are
[Applause]
straight out of the matrix g2e sports
strike first at a potential back to back
split title and a dominant dominant
game three g2 esports are going to pad
their kda's ever so slightly since
gets caught up by this shadow dash taunt
from expect and sanchez is running for
his life mithy turns his attention speed
is dominating
six zero eight i believe
g2 are gonna go for this one
[Applause]
to the finals era they are your summer
split champions
and this means so much for both sven
and mithy they have not won a final yet
they've been here so many times
they joined g2 with the goal of winning
the split
going to worlds and they achieved all of
it
g2 rode their championship momentum all
the way to worlds where they were touted
as
europe's greatest hope and then in one
of the most inexplicable disasters in
the history of european league
g2 bombed out of worlds the nexus starts
getting decimated
that's it last night knocks two
and one
[Applause]
clg bounced back with a dominating
victory over
g2 the european chances the european
champions
they're falling apart there's nowhere
left to go
perks is on the front line dodgers and
electro harpoon flashes the second nexus
turret number one is down
rocks peel away from the kills rocks
tigers turn onto the nexus
and the rox tigers eliminate g2 esports
from world 2016. following their
disappointing performance at worlds
g2 returned to the eu lcs with a
vengeance
hell-bent on re-establishing their
regional dominance sven and mithy cut
through 2017 spring season like a hot
knife through butter
there's no nexus turrets he's got one
shot he's got two he's gonna have to
flash around the side expect picks up
exile
but the nexus he's going low there's a
double kill for sved they've managed to
finish it daisy
is going to be the only one left but
there's
oh are you kidding there's one damn hit
left sven gets the quadra kill and
stops unicorns from ending the game and
it was more of the same in the playoffs
g2 double kill for perks samex is left
alone in the base visit chachi
trying to turn around but the nexus
turrets are falling sven
completely clean house in his fight now
burst is behind the final moment he will
indeed
burst has led his team to victory the
nexus is the focus
and this is a g2 dynasty
with zven and mithy in full swing g2
weren't just boasting one of the
strongest bot lanes in the west
they were solidifying themselves as one
of the greatest teams in the history of
european league
msi 2017 was g2's chance to make up for
their horrific performance at worlds
the whole reason that zven and miffy
joined g2 in the first place
was to show the world that europe had
what it took to win an international
title
and they had no intention of failing
twice in that regard
they're all dead it's over and james who
gets the comeback upset
win over flash wolves improving to 1-1
to close out the first day
turtle follows immediately after g2
esports has killed
his solo mid they've routed them they've
aced them
g2 esports they're taking down the nexus
turret
stun team solomon and g2 shots
and international redemption stays alive
g2 e-sports are on to the nexus turret
they were looking to prove to the world
to prove to yours
this is where they belong g2 esports
take down w e
and g are redeemed
zven had made it all the way to an msi
final
the problem was the three-time world
champion he'd be playing in that final
yeah g2 now they they have the
unenviable task
of facing skt to no one's surprise
g2 dropped the first game of the series
and just as it was starting to look like
a wash
like g2 would walk away with nothing
except the privilege of having been
dumpstered by faker in an msi final
they did the unthinkable let's see what
they can pick up for this one one for
zero trick running away against the
shield stays alive make that a two for
zero
a
[Music]
right now they're in the base of skt 30
minutes into this game and g2 they're
dominating
and g2 hoping history can repeat itself
every best survives at 3-1 it's a joke
to some
but maybe it can happen g2 esports about
to strike back
about to close down the game the fourth
death for faker
the ace courtesy of sven in the european
lcs's g2 esports
have tied up the series for one brief
second
g2 made it look as if they had what it
took to do the impossible
g2 went on to lose the series three
games to one
but it didn't matter they'd come within
an inch of destabilizing korea's
dominance
and the hope was that come worlds they'd
be able to finish the job
following their penultimate finish at
msi g2 had a shaky summer season
they finished second in their group
behind fnatic and had to fight
tooth and nail with splice to get past
the first round of the playoffs
and after a five game series
g2 yell their era is not over
and then just like that g2 turned the
jets on
despite being slated to struggle
throughout the knockout stage
g2 went on to earn their fourth
consecutive regional championship and a
spot at that year's worlds
without dropping any more games the
problem was that g2's worlds group was
exceptionally difficult
forced to contend with both samsung
galaxy and royal never give up
g2 had to fight harder than most to stay
alive
and just when they looked to be out they
managed to claw their way back in
g2 focusing down the nexus and g2
esports
demolish rng yes we predicted the teams
that were leading the group to make it
out of it but g2 is trying to make it
a much more dynamic conversation if they
now beat
1907 as well as samsung there is a
very good chance that they will get out
of this group that will put them at four
wins and also keep the possibility of
that three-way tie live
unfortunately g2's 3-3 finish simply
wasn't enough to get them into the
knockout stage
with their contracts about to expire and
with g2 having bombed out of worlds for
the second year in a row
it was clear that zven and mithy might
be looking to make a change
the pair were still considered to be the
best bot lane in europe
if not the west at large and any team
would be happy to have them
i think that this time will give them
you know some time to think
a window of time to think and reflect
and i think it's fantastic so
we love these two guys and and let's see
what comes out of it about a month after
their devastating turnout at worlds
it was announced that the coveted couple
had been picked up by north american
juggernaut team solomid with an ache in
their heart
sven and mithy were going to california
tsm's decision to sign sven and mithy
came in the wake of their equally
disappointing group stage exclusion from
worlds
for years tsm had dominated the nalcs
and yet despite amassing the most titles
of any organization
they'd always struggle to perform
internationally
needless to say tsm's acquisition of
sven and mithy wasn't without its drama
on the eu side of things this marked the
second time in their careers that they'd
been framed as traitors
i understand that a lot of eu fans have
this eu pride thing and it sucks that
every year some of your favorite players
leave your region so it's harder for
you to cheer for them it's hard to grow
a bond to a player i understand it
but i also want you guys to understand
that you have a short
career in esports and you got to do what
is best for yourself
as far as n a was concerned the issue
was with sven
and who he'd been brought in to replace
namely
one of the most storied and successful
80 carries in the history of north
american league
double lift as for the rest of tsm
i'm planning on just destroying them
this whole year
i hope team liquid can have a perfect
record against tsm
[ __ ] on them in the finals if they make
it there uh i want to
absolutely demolish tsm's legacy and
make sure that they regret that decision
the problem was that adored as he was
doublelift success had only ever been
regional
as far as tsm were concerned zven had a
proven track record of being able to do
what doublelift and the vast majority of
north americans
never could perform on the international
stage
when we signed sven i kind of felt like
he was the only player that was suitable
to replace doublelift because doublelift
was one of the best
or still is one of the best 80 carries
in the west and the only person in my
eyes i could really rival him was sven
with doublelift moving to team liquid
and liquid being touted as the only real
challenger to tsm
a rivalry began to take shape between
zven
and the player he was expected to
outclass
the problem was that he didn't at least
not at first looks like there's a
collapse on bottom a lot of damage they
know no oats for cluster plenty of
damage
comes
to liquid no defense left for tsm the
flash oh into the backline looking for
that kill they're likely to get it then
not long for the world
he's gonna fall down doubles getting
revenge yet again in his ex-team
and under 30 minutes blink was gonna
shut down tsm
in the first game of the split and
doublelift gets revenge in his old team
despite their championship clout tsm got
off to an extremely shaky start
they lost three of their first four
matches and by week five
we're trying to recover from a four and
six record in time for playoffs
i feel like we have the manpower
talent or whatever to be a good team and
we have good structure as well we just
something
goes wrong on stage too often i mean to
start playing the same thing in scrims
as on stage
remarkably enough tsm proceeded to go on
a 7-1 run
positioning themselves in a four-way tie
for third
with clutch gaming cloud nine and team
liquid
they managed to carry that momentum into
the tie breaker itself
where they beat out clutch and liquid to
secure that coveted third seed
and then come the quarterfinals it all
fell apart
very long death timers on multiple
members of tsm
the nexus is low the team is down and
clutch
gaming will tie this sucker up bjergsen
has to work
a legitimate miracle to hold this game
now but i don't see it happening ladies
and gentlemen
clutch gaming takes tsm to match point
you don't get any more freebies there
are no more it's okay we'll win the next
one
you either win the next two here or for
the first time in north american lcs
history
you don't pass quarterfinals and for tsm
that is not a reality they want to admit
it's one for one so far support's going
to be traded off
lyrics again and daniel
true to his words will end them today
tsm rounded the game
over and that is the end of this series
and the
end of tsm's perfect record of attending
the playoff finals
clutch gaming will be the first
organization
to deny them their pass to the semis and
will earn their spot
in miami in what was supposed to be
their biggest
year yet tsm had achieved their worst
regional result
it was a disaster and from there it only
got worse
gsm wasn't even able to qualify for msi
took
fifth in the summer season third in the
summer playoffs
and worst of all failed to qualify for
worlds
after getting swept by cloud9 in the
regional finals
it would be the first time that the
storied n a org
would not make it to the game's biggest
stage
going into 2019 it was clear that
changes needed to be made
what wasn't clear is whether they would
work whether zven could go back to being
the be-all
and end-all adc he once was
on december 3rd 2018 it was announced
that miffy
sven's legendary support had been kicked
from tsm it wasn't difficult for me
because i didn't really have to
choose to split up or not
i i just try to look at what happened
and what happened is that we split up it
was also announced
the tsm would be entering a rebuilding
year
in addition to bringing in smoothie as
miffy's replacement
tsm had decided to take a gamble on two
lesser-known players
acadian and broken blade for sven
the aim was to own up to the failure
that was 2018
and recover from it after 2018 i had a
long time to think like okay what the
happened in this year like why did
everything go so wrong was just
this or this or what should i change
next year how should i prepare for next
year
this doesn't happen to me again and i
was thinking i need to make
this worth it i want to make sure i
don't look back at these two years or
three years whatever how many years i'm
here
and think yeah that wasn't worth it that
was the worst time of my life
i want to make sure that these years are
worth it i want to make
the experience i'll remember forever and
for whatever reason
it worked tsm finished the 2019 spring
season only
one win behind cloud nine and the stars
studded liquid
impact tries to get himself something
the shockwave finds nothing
doublelift goes down at tsm will 2-0
team liquid
in the regular spring split
going into playoffs in dominant form tsm
taking down tl their playoff run saw
them take down echo fox 3-1 before
conducting a remarkable reverse sweep of
cloud9 in the semis
it started rough they made the reverse
sweep happen
and tsm will earn their place in st
louis
needless to say there was a tremendous
amount of hype surrounding tsm's final
match-up against team liquid
not only were doublelift and bjergsen
both vying for a sixth lcs title
but the rivalry between doublelift and
zven hadn't subsided in the slightest
because douglas is good right he's
skilled and he can carry games by
himself
but when he can't carry because his
opponent is as good as him or
maybe even better so unless tl steps
massively for
the playstyle i'm confident that match
against them i feel bad for this van
especially because
all the fans just say man the team was
so much better when doublelift was here
and it must make him feel like [ __ ] all
the time
which is actually really good for me
because i have like this mental
advantage over him
24 7. more importantly sven was
determined to set a record of his own
but for me it's like something else
because i'm the only player right now
that can
still win both in lcs and ulcs and for
me it's like
something important just for myself
it would be so dope to be the first
person to win both you know
considering that liquid were the clear
favorites and back to back defending
champions
it was rather surprising to see tsm take
game one
and now for the last few kills tsm are
just
wreaking havoc a double kill making a
triple in his first lcs finals
and he won david do they
and the next is more important tsm
1-0 it was even more surprising to see
them take game two
tsm ensuring it is theirs and they are
one game away
from returning to their legacy tsf 2-0
but liquid were resilient and
on the brink of defeat they rallied
[Applause]
and the rest of team liquid will answer
back
we will go to game four and team liquid
will hope
for the reverse sweep for their third
straight title
a 25-minute win team liquid
bring us to game five and that one
is anyone's game but come game five
tsm managed to swing the momentum back
in their favor
liquid was getting obliterated and it
was starting to look like there was
no way for them to climb back in tsm
will take the ace and the infernal
dragon
and then this happened so far tsm has
outmaneuvered
no quick silver sash he is down
he is shut down what is he doing to
baron
on the back of a misplay that will go on
to live in infamy
sven single-handedly allowed liquid to
mount a comeback
and ultimately hoist a trophy that sven
himself was
all but guaranteed to hold what is the
objective that we are fighting for here
did he
die trying to get the [ __ ] spire
control why
wreck-sized bot lane
what are we doing and yet despite the
fact that zven has since
faced a lot of flack for that maneuver
it takes more than one mistake to throw
an entire series
i'm sorry
[Music]
it's okay i think all of us could have
made a lot of better decisions
i think everyone had bad moments yeah
yeah
where each person could have won
different games
[Music]
sven is a three-time eu lcs champion
he's finished top four at worlds top two
at msi
and in both cases met his defeat at the
hands of the greatest player to ever
live
the fact that he's gone from an
international contender to squabbling
over domestic titles in n
a isn't lost on him i wanted so much
more
because you want you always want what
you can't have that's just how it works
for humans in general right you always
want what you can't have
and come to america was a new challenge
for me as a person as a player
my career is all i have in my life
sounds a little sad but
it's really my career is everything to
me at the end of the day
sven is one of the greatest western adcs
of all time
period that's not going to change just
because his career as an import
hasn't panned out the way he thought it
would his story is far from over
and he won't stop until he's made his
return to the top
so i'm giving it my everything every day
every day i imagine myself
winning the finals i tell myself what am
i gonna do when i win am i gonna stand
and scream or am i just gonna
jump around and i'm thinking about that
moment every day and this is it's all i
think about
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages